Ronald McDonald he's a beloved character
of American culture an icon of culinary
achievement and a symbol of fun
community and childhood Nostalgia for
Generations Ronald is a reminder of fun
trips to McDonald's chowing down on
Happy Meals exploring colorful play
places and celebrating the values of
Friendship with a smile
smile smile everybody come on
aile or is he why is it that this
supposed Bastion of fun and happiness
according to the McDonald's Corporation
is perceived as creepy and unsettling by
the general public what other supposedly
kid-friendly fast food mascot finds
himself tied over and over to
nightmarish urban legends disgusting
controversies and bizarre impersonations
why is it that if you simply Google
Ronald McDonald half the results look
like this and this and this why is the
official company image of this character
so vastly different from the discourse
surrounding
him the Ronald McDonald statue looked
down at this guy and said I'm tired
too
wooho Ronald McDonald lurks in the ball
pits waiting to grab onto your
leg like that is so creepy
dude he gazed up at me with this
disturbing smile uh oh there's trouble
to float Billy and made Ronald a
he guys they brought back Ronald
McDonald Michaela can barely contain
herself after hearing Ronald McDonald is
back Ronald McDonald is now delivering
Smiles
online watch
this this is not fit for human
consumption family sued McDonald's
McDonald's is a target of a major
lawsuit McDonald's is being sued for
almost a billion dollars the officers
say with its red hair and golden color
outfit they knew exactly who this was it
left a young girl disfigured Ronald
McDonald's brand identity is one of
happiness and welcoming inviting
personality for children and I can't
tell you how many parents will call and
inquire because their kids are freaking
out they're not loving it we are slaves
we have new God instead of the old God
and we pray for
[Music]
McDonald's
welcome to Horror history good morning
class good morning M earlier this year I
made a Horror history episode on Grimace
the frightening Shake obsessed purple
blob of nightmare fuel who came back in
2023 to terrorize a new generation in
making that video I ended up
rediscovering a lot of disturbing
information about the ring leader
himself Ronald McDonald Ronald was first
introduced as a new McDonald mascot in
1963 taking over duties from the
original mascot Speedy a perpetually
winking or maybe cyclop chef with a
burger for a head and a pench for
productivity named after the Speedy
service system that co-founders Maurice
and Richard McDonald used for their
original restaurants but according to
mash.com Speedy was dropped due to
Market Research showing that the golden
arches themselves were a more iconic
marketing symbol so when it came time to
produce TV commercials in the 1960s a
new mascot was developed the original
Ronald was a spiritual successor to Bozo
the Clown with a red and yellow striped
jumpsuit a shake cup for a nose a
cardboard tray as a hat and a crazy look
in his eye giving him more of an
appearance of an unhinged hobo than a
circus performer Ronald's appearance
would change over the years with the
intention of appealing more to children
and while it is normal for any corporate
mascot to be created with the intention
of advertising to the youth Ronald's
targeting of prepubescence gets much
darker than any of the competition
except for maybe Jared from Subway that
guy was kind of surprisingly if we look
closely at the official McDonald's
messaging we can see proof of occult
activities being performed by Ronald
right out in open air but to understand
how a children's character became so
synonymous with horror we've got to take
it all the way back to his
[Music]
birth
Willard Scott was born on March 7th 1934
from a young age he took an interest in
broadcasting and formed a radio club in
his neighborhood with other boys after
some success in radio he moved on to
television in the 1950s mostly appearing
in Children's shows like Barn party
afternoon Commander retro and Bozo the
Clown even then he wanted to gain
influence over kids but we wouldn't find
out why for some time originally created
as a mascot for Capital Records Bozo was
spun off into his own franchise with
different actors playing him in
different local radio stations Scot
played Bozo on wrct TV from 1959 to 1962
when the show was cancelled a year later
one of the show's sponsors McDonald
approached Scott about helping them
develop a character for three local
commercial spots in Washington DC and
the result was Ronald McDonald he mostly
looked the same as Bozo borrowing the
bright red smile curved eyebrows and
exaggerated collar but what Willard
Scott created was more than just a new
character it was a new identity a change
Ain to normae Baker saying goodbye to
her old life to become Marilyn Monroe
Stephanie gerota's transformation into
to Lady Gaga or Shane Le yaw's
rebranding to become Shane Dawson you
could say that Ronald McDonald was truly
born that day but for the purposes of
making my thumbnail look more impressive
I will not also there's this one
commercial where Ronald reminisces about
his childhood and losing his first tooth
where he was still a clown but I think
it's safe to say that this is a
fictionalized version of the events but
don't tell that to the McDonald's
corporation who still insist that Ronald
McDonald is a real person making no
mention of any
actors introducing the the world's
newest silliest and hamburger eating as
clown Ronald
McDonald now where is that clown oh
Ronald Ronald Ronald hey Ronald Here I
Am Kid yep the world's first
introduction to Ronald would be in a
dark room crouched over an analog TV
addressing a group of children in secret
knowing that it's kind of shocking that
nobody figured out this guy would become
a thing of nightmares he was so in touch
with his scary side that in just his
second commercial he ended up inspiring
one one of the greatest horror icons of
all time Pennywise from Stephen King's
It why isn't that McDonald's hamburger
delicious mom told me never to talk to
strangers hi
Georgie don't you want a balloon I'm not
supposed to take stuff from The
Strangers my dad said so well your
mother's right as always but I'm Ronald
McDonald's give me a McDonald's shake
very wise of your dad Georgie very wise
indeed I Georgie and Penny wise the
Dancing
Clown you are
Georgie so now we know each other but
these seemingly predatory lines are not
the only similarity that Ronald shares
with Pennywise and these initial
commercials all contain a clue to
understanding his true
motivation if Ronald is doing his job
correctly then I'm sure this video has
you craving some mouthwatering fast food
well stop don't do that cuz I have a way
better option for you because today's
video is sponsored by factor factor
delivers fresh never Frozen dietitian
approved meals right to your door no
more grocery trips or cooking just heat
and eats delicious nutritious meals in 2
minutes I'm often up late editing videos
so having Factor meals ready to grab is
a lifesaver their food is not only
seriously tasty but Factor offsets 100%
of delivery emissions and uses renewable
electricity it's easy to feel good about
enjoying their meals delicious healthy
and sustainable and with the holidays
coming up using Factor you can skip the
grocery trips chopping prepping and
cleanup while still getting getting
flavorful nutritious meals Factor sent
me some of their premium Gourmet plus
meals to try the steak is perfectly
cooked and tender after reheating and
the sides like broccolini and leaks are
restaurant quality it's actually a lot
faster than fast food I don't have to
worry about chopping or prepping either
I just heat and eat best of all factors
offering a face melting deal for my
viewers head to factor75.com or click
the link below and use code cz50 to get
50% off your first Factor box now I can
finish this video without being tempted
to turn to junk food thanks again factor
for sponsoring and providing some
amazing meals
[Music]
in the initial round of Ronald McDonald
commercials there's one often overlooked
Oddity that puts Ronald on a different
level than Bozo the Clown Ronald has the
ability to wield magic and he even says
as much in his first commercial magic
tray here keeps me well supplied
McDonald's hamburgers french fries and
milkshake in his second ad he uses the
tray to gain the trust of a child well
you sound like Ronald here I'll prove it
I'll give you three more hamburgers
I know you're not supposed to accept
gifts from strangers either but you're
no stranger you really are Ronald
McDonald in an interview with the Food
Network Ronald eventually admitted his
true goal with these commercials and the
design of his character there was
something about the combination of
hamburgers and Bozo that was
irresistible to
kids can we think of anyone else who
used magic to take the form of a clown
to lure in children it reminds me a lot
of this passage from chapter 21 in it
the fears of children were simpler and
usually more powerful the fears of
children could often be summoned up in a
single phase and if bait were needed why
what child did not love a clown that
brings me to the third Ronald McDonald
commercial in which Ronald grabs onto a
rocket and flies to the Moon where there
is already a McDonald's restaurant
clearly more magic was employed to make
this happen and clearly this is another
parallel shared with Pennywise the
Dancing Clown who initially came to
Earth as a crash landing meteor from
Outer spad as I mentioned in our world
Penny wise is nothing more than a
fictional character that was inspired
part espcially by Ronald McDonald but
perhaps Stephen King came to realize the
true horror of Ronald's power and
fictionalized it as a warning to all of
us Ronald is brought up no less than
three times in King's novel most notably
by Don Hagerty who after witnessing
Pennywise kill his boyfriend claimed
that the clown looked like a cross
between Ronald McDonald and Boza
Ronald's plan seemed to be working
because after these initial commercials
which aired around Washington DC he
became a local celebrity and gained a
lot of influence over children near the
nation's capital this led to him being
introduced nationally in 1966 before
appearing on the national stage Ronald
got his first of many makeovers dropping
the drink cup nose and Trey hat and
adopting a more traditional clown
costume is it coincidence that this look
would seemingly go on to inspire serial
killer John Wayne gasy or was that
simply the standard clown look at the
time I'll let you decide in what some
sources have documented as the First
National Commercial Ronald helps paint a
McDonald sign sticks around for lunch
then takes off in his flying hamburger
mobile obviously another demonstration
of his occult power another commercial
once again shows him using magic to
conjure McDonald's menu items to fuel
his flying Burg mobile I love how this
early commercial really takes the time
to demonstrate how Ronald can easily
become a source of fear when his vehicle
backfires just listen to their
screens looks like I'm having trouble
getting started over the next couple
years he gained a lot of recognition
starring in commercials during the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade and NFL
championship game but most of the ads
played on children's programming why was
there such a great focus on targeting
kids in one particularly creepy
commercial from the 1960s he possibly
reveals the true motivation when he's
unloading food from a carry out bag and
discovers a child inside hey you sure
can get a lot in these bags can you it's
never made clear if Ronald was planning
on eating that child but photos from the
time do demonstrate a chilling contrast
between a very elated looking Ronald and
a very uncomfortable looking child with
the success of these initial commercials
the McDonald's corporation went all in
on Advertising the kids in 1970 they put
Ronald in a series of comics sold on new
stands and the following year Ronald was
promoted to Chief happiness officer
which came with a relocation into
McDonald Land home to many other
McDonald's characters like officer Big
Mac Mayor McCheese the professor the
Hamburglar Captain crook the goblins and
the evil GRS McDonald Land is basically
a preserve where fast food items can be
found growing in nature but it's also
kind of weird that most of the
inhabitants like officer Big Mac and
Mayor McCheese are fast food items
themselves pretty much every character
plays into this theme of law versus
crime but why is the law enforcing a
culture that encourages human kids
feasting down on their own people is
Mayor mcch not worried about about these
kids developing a taste for his own
flesh by eating at McDonald's the only
reasonable explanation is that Ronald
with his new CH position at the
McDonald's corporation is the one
pulling the strings here he's trying to
fatten these kids up for something
perhaps some kind of ritual most of the
commercials feature Ronald's doing
something to outsmart and stop one of
the villainous characters from stealing
McDonald's food which again is readily
available to be picked and eaten in
nature one of these commercials features
Ronald pulling items out of a magic Top
Hat it's not outside the typical scope
of work for clown to perform magic but
what is striking is that this is
basically the only kind of performance
that he does up to this point we haven't
seen him juggling riding a unicycle
miming or doing any other activities
typically associated with being a clown
Ronald could easily have chosen to make
himself a hamburger magician but he
didn't do that why because he wants to
appeal to kids he's constantly saying
things to make himself seem more
relatable to kids who he constantly
refers to as the boys and girls now
McDonald's everywhere will have plenty
of scrumptious cherry pies for boys and
girls to enoy jooy anytime since
Pennywise seems to be modeled after
Ronald it's probably safe to use it as a
reference its power literally comes from
consuming the kids's fear take all of
you as I'll Feast on your flesh as I
feed on your fear there's not enough
evidence so far to say that Ronald is
eating the children but I do think
they're connected to his ability to
harness magic which by the way is
getting more and more unsettling take
this commercial from the 1970s where a
boy named Aaron first discovers the
McDonald's playl welcome Eric to
McDonald's land yep the statue has begun
talking oh my God why the close-ups what
is happening of course it's me and all
your other friends too come on in and
look around why does that sound so
threatening I just want you to remember
that in the' 7s the statue talks in an
official McDonald's production just in
case oh I don't know the company tries
to deny something like this happening
later on this was actually a short film
directed at prospective McDonald's
franchisees to educate them on the
newest option to increase business at
their stores the installation of a
McDonald's Playland Ronald and the other
characters had become so popular that
their likenesses were being used in
playground equipment at McDonald's
restaurants however as we have seen with
many popular characters over the years
with clout often comes controversy and
Ronald McDonald was about to be taken to
[Music]
court have you ever heard the term sued
out of existence turns out it's not just
hyperbole that's exactly what the
McDonald Land characters were facing
when Sid and Marty Croft the creators of
the children's television show HR Puffin
stuff sued Ronald in the gang for their
resemblance to the Puffin stuff
characters starting in 1973 the main
point of contention was Mayor McCheese
who was accused of infringing the
copyright of Mayor HR Puffin stuff
himself it was a long and hard-fought
Affair but in the end Puffin stuff and
the crof brothers were victorious which
is especially surprising considering
that mayor MC chees himself is also
theing judge in McDonald Land order
Order in the Court during the surely
very expensive lawsuit the characters
are forced to sleep outside in beds I
don't know if McDonald Land typically
has a very rainy climate but snow is
certainly not out of the question
perhaps to save face against the bad
press generated by the legal proceedings
Ronald decided to start his own charity
Foundation aptly titled the Ronald
McDonald House kind of ironic
considering that he was still living in
a group of beds sitting in an open field
but Ronald McDonald House provided
shelter and support to families of
children undergoing surgeries and
medical care it was a very successful
program but it would eventually be the
center of some appalling horror stories
more on that later also during the Croft
Brothers litigation McDonald's produced
a series of toys showcasing the
characters of their McDonald Land
commercial cast I talked about this in
the Grimace video but these are some
pretty terror-inducing figurines as
someone who has now been through the
process of producing a figurine I don't
know how McDonald's and Remco messed up
so badly these children's toys make your
flesh creep with one of the worst
offenders being Huggy the tree whose
appearance has already been described as
uncomfortable and just upsetting but
Ronald the leader of the pack was not to
be outdone because they made the toy
just have these pitch black eyes it
would be easy to chalk this up to poor
toy design but I think there's something
more here there are several other
instances of Ronald's eyes going pitch
black it can even be seen on more modern
official posts from the Ronald McDonald
Instagram this may be something
involuntary that happens to Ronald from
time to time like perhaps after the use
of dark magic and it just so happened to
occur while he was being photograph for
the action figure Ronald's dabbling in
the occult is starting to become more
evident in 1977 Sid Marty Croft won the
lawsuit against McDonald's and although
there would be an appeal and another 10
years of legal fighting many characters
were forced to retire in the 1980s as
they were slowly phased out of McDonald
Land including Mayor McCheese officer
Big Mac Captain Crook and the professor
Ronald luckily made the cut he and the
other remaining characters would
continue to star in commercials like
this one where Ronald uses his magic
pogo stick to meet the man in the moon
no not that moonman internet users maybe
we'll get to him in a different episode
he actually goes to the moon again and
again and again and again they love
sending Ronald to the Moon maybe there
really is some deeper connection he also
started a commercial promoting the
flying McNuggets where the clown is in
an actual circus for once he was also
there in 1986 for the arrival of Birdie
the early bird's egg it seems that he
and the Gang are still sleeping outside
which really raises some questions about
how much they actually make from all
these commercial gits I was wondering
earlier what they do during inclement
weather and that seems to be answered in
this commercial midnight at McDonald's
where we find out he just sleeps on the
floor in the kitchen at
McDonald's
Donald hey we got to get ready for the
kids tomorrow imagine being a fry cook
who works at McDonald's and you forget
something and have to go back at night
you fumble around in the dark and that's
when you hear snoring coming from right
below you you slowly look down to find a
man in full clown attire passed out on
the floor sounds about As relaxing as
being the night security at Freddy
Fazbear's Pizza the main difference with
Ronald's appearances in the'80s is that
many of them take place in our world
rather than McDonald Land he teaches a
class of burger stars in musical numbers
dances with trash cans travels through
time feeds a robot McDonald's food for
some reason feeds an alien McDonald's
food produces a play produces a movie
becomes a private investigator becomes a
Competitive Cyclist becomes a newspaper
publisher joins a folk band joins a rock
band joins A hip-hop group joins the
military plays piano takes a sleigh ride
shows off his ice skating skills plays
some baseball plays some basketball
lifts some weights competes in several
Olympic sports climbs a mountain goes on
a treasure hunt goes to the library goes
to Transylvania goes on a submarine
Voyage goes to fairy tale land goes to
the Mushroom Kingdom creates a portal to
a winter realm and puts the chicken
McNuggets to bed which is kind of
terrifying from their perspective and
through everything eats a really
concerning amount of McDonald's food
while somehow putting on a no visible
weight another difference is that
Grimace and the Hamburglar are now
friends with Ronald rather than enemies
they take part in the kids product Mania
of the 1980s with Ronald and Grimace
appearing in a children's book and even
an animated short film that played at
birthday parties inside McDonald's
restaurants one of Ronald's greatest
Rivals Charles entertainment cheese was
going through a rough patch at the time
one of many rough patches actually so
the clown decided to kick him W he's
down and steal one of his main sources
of income birthday parties there's food
fun and games for the kids and even a
special McDonald's birthday cake a
McDonald's birthday party gives him
something to remember all year long yes
because being surrounded by a huddle of
friends wearing Grimace hats is exactly
how I want to spend my birthday anyway
the short film that played for birthdays
features Ronald and friends in a series
of Adventures across space and time in a
vehicle called The Adventure machine
which looks an awful lot like HG Well's
time machine you would think they'd be
more careful about potential
intellectual property theft after
literally just getting sued but nothing
would come out of this but since this
movie is animated there's this part
where Ronald's head is in the foreground
and at first I thought Grimace had just
opened his mouth ridiculously wide
open this short came out in 1987 but
Ronald's biggest claim to Hollywood Fame
was yet to come the following year when
he would appear in a major motion
picture
hi kids it's me Ronald McDonald and I'm
on the set of my very first motion
picture ever it's a movie called Mac and
Me and I want to introduce you to
him Mac and Me was a blatant ripoff of
ET the 1982 hit directed by Steven
Spielberg the movie featured a
12-year-old boy who befriends an
alien accidentally brought back to Earth
by a NASA rover the alien becomes known
as Mac presumably named after the Big
Mac McDonald's signature menu item
something I've been telling you about
the Mac what the mysterious alien
creature according to thrillist the
film's producer RJ Lewis claims
similarities to the Big Mac are a
complete coincidence which is very
difficult to believe because of the
Relentless product placement throughout
the entire rest of the movie rather than
a bad movie that's occasionally
interrupted by some product placement
Mac and Me is an hour and a half long
commercial occasionally interrupted by a
movie though the people involved claimed
that the movie was not directly funded
by McDonald's it was part of a vision to
sell movie products through the
McDonald's brand and it may have been
funded by McDonald's supplier Golden
State Foods et's popularity had helped
boost the sales of Reese's Pieces 6
years earlier so it seems that RJ Lewis
maybe believe that his movie could do
the same thrill states that Lewis had
worked on McDonald's campaigns in the
past and remained close with Ronald
McDonald House charities in other words
Ronald himself was Lewis's Inn to
acquire the rights to use the McDonald's
brand from Ronald's perspective there
was no reason to help Lewis with this
except for the opportunity to be exposed
to more kids Ronald was already
considered one of the most famous faces
on the planet at this point some of the
proceeds of the movie would also be
donated to Ronald's charity the film
opened on August 12 1988 and Ronald's
appearance is a brief Cameo during a
birthday party at McDonald's despite the
limited scope of his role he still
managed to win an award for his
performance the award was the golden
raspberry award for worst new star and
the movie as a whole was very poorly
received grossing just $6 million on a
13 million budget and being pulled after
just 2 weeks this utter humiliation
seemed not to deter Ronald from
continuing to Branch out into other
medians the following year he started a
Japanese Nintendo game called donaldland
which has creepy faces and horror
elements written all over
it what the hell is that thing in the
game Ronald has to save his friends from
a series of eldrich Abominations it's
interesting that the final boss is also
a magic wielding clown is this
ultimately what Ronald will become if he
continues down this path of sorcery and
Witchcraft time would tell in the 1990s
his cult continued to grow with the 1990
directed video release The Adventures of
Ronald McDonald MC Treasure Island in
1992 he almost seems to be openly
inviting children to join the cult when
he releases a new ad campaign called do
you believe in
magic he also crossed into the US video
game Market with a video game adaptation
called McDonald's Treasure Land
adventure for the Sega up to this point
despite a a few eyebrow raising
incidents Ronald mostly had a very clean
image it's very easy for me to cherry
pick moments where he seemed creepy but
over his first 30 years with the company
there are really only a handful of
examples he was an icon of Pop Culture
with a devoted fan base or perhaps Cult
of young children supporting his every
move but it's during the 1990s that
rumors of sinister Behavior start to
rise to the surface literally let's
rewind a couple years remember how I
said that Ronald wanted to kick his
pizza snarfing rival Charles while he
was down in the 1980s by offering
birthday parties that wasn't the only
shot fired at chuck-e-cheese's because
in 1987 McDonald's introduced the
McDonald's play play a softer more
colorful indoor playground attraction
with slides games and the ball pits ball
pits were popping up at kid-friendly
fast food establishments all over the
country which gave way to a lot of urban
legends combined that with a faster
spread of information during the early
days of the internet and email and these
Legends started to become widespread
according to about.com's Urban Legends
page it started in 1998 with rumors of a
three-year-old receiving what appeared
to be a Ratt snake bite in a Burger King
ball pit in South Carolina McDonald's
would have their own version of the
controversy a year later in November
1999 when a new viral email was passed
around a woman named Lauren Archer
claimed she took her three-year-old son
Kevin to a McDonald's restaurant in
Sugarland Texas and found a welt on him
in the bath the next day he was vomiting
his eyes rolled back in his head and he
was taken to the emergency room where he
died later that night the autopsy
revealed that Kevin had died from a
heroin overdose and the welt was caused
by a needle broken off inside of him
according to the email police emptied
the ball pit to find rotten food several
hypodermic needles knives candy diapers
feces and the stench of urine while this
specific story has been debunked there
was no Kevin who died of a heroin
overdose in or around Sugarland that
month it is widely believed that it
comes from a place of Truth and
McDonald's employees do find things like
hypodermic needles and rotten food in
the playpl ball pits during cleaning
just look at this WebMD article from
2001 which provides safety tips for
playing in the ball pit confirming that
such items have been reported at the
bottom but just why do these dangerous
items keep appearing at the bottom of
ball pits the question may have already
been answered we've seen Ronald's living
situation change a couple times from an
open field in McDonald Land to just
laying on the floor in the kitchen at
McDonald's it stands to reason that when
the play places were built in the late
80s Ronald would have wanted to migrate
over there once the lights were out and
the place was locked up the ball pit
would be a much more comfortable place
to sleep than the dirty kitchen floor
and the items at the bottom were
probably a combination of McDonald's
food dropped by kids and his own
personal possessions the reason why I
bring up this theory is because not long
after the alleged needle incident
stories of Ronald McDonald himself being
spotted in the ball pits began to
circulate and one night when an employee
was shutting down the restaurant he
walked into the play place just to make
sure that everybody was out before he
shut it down turned off the lights
locked the doors and from the side of
his eye he saw this shadowed figure in
the distance it was just crouched
amongst the colored balls as if this
employee was the prey and he was about
to get pounced on so he decided to look
over very slowly and he swears that he
saw this red hair and pale face before
it quickly sunk underneath the surface
how creepy is that other stories are
told from the kid's perspective like he
hides in the ball pin in which a kid
playing hideand-seek in the tunnels is
chased by the colorful mascot over the
years I've come to realize the only way
the guy could have been in there with us
as if he had been hiding there all along
maybe from the night before just beneath
the bar balls in the ball pit waiting
for his opportunity to strike at the end
of the day urban legends are just that
Legends stories that are passed around
but are unauthenticated but I do find it
kind of suspicious that as soon as these
stories of Ronald living in the ball
pits started to gain traction the
McDonald's corporation was ready with a
distraction in 1998 they began
Distributing VHS tapes and Happy Meals
containing a new miniseries called The
Wacky Adventures of Ronald McDonald the
series would run for six episodes in
each of the early episodes Ronald gets a
call about some kind of Adventure then
Springs into action by jumping into
the oh my god let's go
Sunday many of Ronald's Adventures
almost sound like Horror Stories episode
one sees Ronald and friends going
camping but Sheltering in a haunted
house when it rains episode 2 details a
voyage to Grimace Island a terrifying
Concept in itself episode three deals
with the Hamburglar being abducted by
aliens and Ronald's taking everyone in
his spaceship to go rescue him because
Ronald will use literally any excuse to
go to space in episode 4 they're all
trapped in an abandoned amusement park
and experimented on by an evil Professor
episode 5 is another time travel episode
they visit the Jurassic period Medieval
Times the wild west and even the 1970s
where they run into mayor MC chees which
actually makes a lot of sense this would
be shortly before the Croft Brothers
lwuit finally in episode 6 they meet a
mad scientist who creates a monster to
terrorize a town in Scotland hey if you
thought McDonald Land lock was fun watch
for an even wackier Adventure coming
soon that would never happen the show
ran for from 1998 to 2003 at which point
Ronald and the Gang were cancelled by
the McDonald's corporation although he
didn't know it yet this would be the
beginning of the end for this calerie
promoting circus
Clan Jaslin Bradley loved her McDonald's
super sized a McMuffin in the morning
and the Big Mac meal with an apple pie
in the evening was standard operating
procedure Ashley pelman was more of a
Happy Meal girl she liked the prizes
that's what readers saw on page one of
the New York Times on November 21st 2002
the two teens were suing McDonald's for
making them obese claiming they did not
provide necessary information about the
health risks and their lawyer Samuel
Hirsch said that the fast food Giants
billion- dooll advertising campaign
encouraged children to make unhealthy
choices offering that young individuals
are not in a position to make a choice
after the onslaught of advertising and
promotions once again Ronald found
himself in the Crosshair of a Judicial
Jou but unlike the puff and stuff
scuffle this time he found himself at
the center of it as the one directly
responsible for advertising the food to
Children according to the New York Times
article McDonald's denied making the
children the target of its advertising I
have no idea how they got away with that
we literally have dozens of clips of
Ronald directly addressing the kids or
the boys and girls many of which I've
shown in this video but I'm not a lawyer
and I imagine after the last suit Ronald
got himself some good ones and
ultimately this case was thrown out but
the legal victory was not a moral one
because this was really bad press for
the company and primarily for Ronald and
it was about to get a whole lot worse I
mean what would happen if I ate nothing
but McDonald's for 30 days straight
would I suddenly be on the fast track to
becoming an obese American would it be
unreasonably dangerous let's find out
I'm ready super siize me this is Morgan
Spurlock a documentary filmmaker from
West Virginia who saw jasine in Ashley's
lawsuit and wondered how dangerous a
McDonald's diet really was on day two he
was throwing up in the parking lot at
the end of the Third week he experienced
heart palpitations and at the end of the
experiment he' gained 25 lbs lost his
energy lost his libido and became
depressed this documentary was a huge
deal when it was released on May 7th
2004 it was honored at Sundance
nominated for an Oscar and grossed $12
million twice as much as Mack and me it
made the term supersize me a bigger
cultural phenomenon than ever and not in
a positive way and the part with the law
professor who was leading the legal
attack against the fast food industry
really struck a cord with people
McDonald's is one of the biggest but
more more importantly it lures in young
children a second cut of the film was
edited for use in schools I remember
watching it in school myself and to this
day I can't remember eating a
non-breakfast meal at Mickey D's that
does not include drinks as you may know
the McDonald's corporation of course has
spies everywhere and was well aware of
the storm that was brewing in McDonald
Land the do you believe in magic ad
campaign had been retired in 97 and they
unsuccessfully tested a series of other
slogans in the meantime the company was
moving away from Ronald as a whole kids
seem to be losing their belief in Magic
and were more interested in hip-hop
Ronald had a new rival within the
company and his name was Justin
[Music]
Timberlake in September they would
launch the I'm loving it campaign and
this marked a turning point for the
company and for Ronald they had just put
out their new Go Active menu the day
before suiz me's release which is
speculated to have been a PR counter
move the following month they
discontinued the super siiz option Walt
rker the same guy who claimed McDonald's
advertising does not Target children
told CBS News the driving force behind
the decision was menu simplification so
how did this affect Ronald for one he
was kept from the public eye overall
appearing in way less commercials
instead the commercials in the 2000s
focused on relatability to real people
mostly older teens and young adults
using the promise of winning huge prizes
which would become a whole separate
Scandal when Ronald did appear in
commercials he was as far as I could
find always doing something active like
playing sports or Dance Dance
Revolution
Ronald began to Showcase incredible
athletic abilities that we had never
seen before McDonald invested an
estimated 65 million to become the
official restaurants of the 2004 Olympic
Games in Athens Greece which resulted in
a series of ads where Ronald competes in
Olympic figure skating skiing hammer
throw synchronized swim and Diving he
also did a Japanese ad where he appeared
in the 2006 World Baseball
[Music]
[Applause]
Classic I'm
it he also continued his new tradition
of starring in a straight to video
miniseries every eight years by
releasing mck kids adventures in 2006
does anyone find it a little disturbing
that they refer to it as Mick kids the
same prefix that they used to refer to a
variety of McDonald's menu items such as
McNuggets McChicken MCD duble MC rib MC
flurry McMuffin MC wrap and MC Krispy
anyway the first episode stays on the
exercise theme titled get up and go with
Ronald in it he teaches kids how to burn
some McDonald's calories by acting of
Transportation playing soccer and flying
kites which is not an exercise but okay
and there's this one kid who sucks at
everything she does and Ronald gives her
some extra guidance and then they all
perform in a rock band together like in
School of Rock throughout the show
Ronald can be seen using magic to
enhance the experience showing us that
although he isn't seen using his powers
much in the New Millennium he still has
access to them after this treasure hunt
with Ronald would be the last episode of
the shortlived series only having lasted
two episodes it was becoming clear that
Ronald's popularity with kids was
falling he hardly appeared at all in the
late 2000s decade and seemed to spend
more time working on building his
charity the Ronald McDonald House which
celebrated its 25th anniversary in 2009
but he was unpopular with kids who were
more interested in real rappers and
athletes unpopular with parents who saw
him as the reason for their ballooning
obesity and unpopular with consumer
advocacy groups who took out full page
ads in major newspapers to protest the
marketing of junk food to kids his
likeness was even placed in a 2010 short
film called logorama where he plays the
murderous drag racing antagonist
interesting detail about this film he's
is finally caught after tripping on a
Weight Watcher logo in 2010 things
reached a boiling point this next story
is ridiculous last week a watchdog group
came out and wanted fast food
restaurants to stop giving away toys and
their meals because they said it
promoted childhood obesity now they want
McDonald's to whack Ronald McDonald
corporate accountability says a recent
poll shows 47% of people think it is
time for Ronald to retire corporate
accountability International is calling
on Ronald to retire even though he's a
lot skinnier than he used to
be
it seemed like everyone was coming for
Ronald's head that is coming for his
head as a figure of speech until 2011
when a Finnish food activist group
kidnapped him over complaints about the
ingredients used in McDonald's food and
then they made their demands now this is
in Finish we love burgers fries and
McDonald's but we can no longer Watch
Silent when the food we love is being
destroyed when McDonald's refused to
respond the food activist released a
second video of a Ronald statue being
beheaded by a guillotine Ronald was
eventually able to work some kind of
magic to get out of that tricky
situation but after that he seemed to
fall into a complete downward spiral
hysteria would ensue and at the center
of it all was a false
it it was 1972 when we first saw
Ronald's ability to possess a statue one
of the more offbeat questionable uses of
his power for sure but at the time
seemingly innocent enough there had been
another more suspect incident in 2004
around the time that Ronald became
Public Enemy Number One or at least
that's what this next urban legend
alleges see even as Ronald was slowly
being scrubbed from McDonald's marketing
strategies he still remained in most
restaurants in the form of these statues
one night two guys visited McDonald's
after attending a nightclub in cor noaca
Mexico late at night they both sat on
the bench next to Ronald to eat their
food and while one friend got up to
throw his Trash Away the other laid his
head on Ronald's lap and said I'm tired
just then Ronald's head a turned down to
look at him and said I'm tired too
according to this version of The Legend
This was captured via security camera
and McDonald's paid a huge sum of money
to local police to cover up the incident
the story faded into relative obscurity
but as pressure continued to mount
against Ronald more weird stories about
Ronald statues began to pop up they
began appearing in strange places places
where McDonald's statues weren't
supposed to be then in 2011 this video
was uploaded to YouTube it appears to be
possibly another security tape of a
statue in Mexico
the video title translates to Spooky
Ronald moves strange photos floated
around the internet of Ronald statues
seemingly assaulting the children that
he was supposed to be entertaining
around 2013 the Ronald McDonald House
creepy pasta was created a creepy pasta
is a horror related urban legend that is
shared virally around the internet this
story focuses on a different type of
Ronald McDonald's house basically a
halfway house for troubled orphans where
kids are secretly crucified and have
their blood drained by nurses is in
clown makeup the end of the story
features the narrator escaping to an
abandoned McDonald's restaurant and
seeing the Ronald McDonald statue began
laughing in 2016 photos were shared with
the New York Post of Chinese police
arresting a Ronald McDonald statue
similar incidents continued to occur in
the United States investigators aren't
saying what Clues they have right now
but people who live here tell me secrets
don't stay that way for long in this
town of 2500 here at the McDonald's on
University Boulevard West employees were
seen sweeping up broken glass at least
two windows are missing and are being
boarded
up it almost seemed as McDonald's
corporate stripped Ronald of more
commercial responsibilities he
retaliated by possessing statues to
cause Mayhem almost as if he needed to
be in the Limelight and if the company
wasn't going to place him there he would
find another way to get attention
there's no way anyone could prove that
the real Ronald was responsible but the
message was clear and I think McDonald's
understood that message because in 2014
14 they tried to make the character Work
One Last Time by giving him another
makeover in an attempts to make him less
scary to kids the jumpsuit was replaced
by a vest and cargo pants there was even
a more formal sports coat for special
occasions in an attempt to further
relate to this new generation of kids
Ronald got his own Instagram account
though whether this made him less or
more scary is certainly Up For Debate
maybe being more spontaneous in these
photos resulted in some less flattering
angles that made him look even more
scary oh I wish that scary looking clown
at the end of my bed would go away
[Music]
but that's just me cherry-picking again
these photos mostly did no harm but
didn't really help his popularity like
he expected he reached 27,000 followers
by 2016 not much compared to one of his
Rivals Wendy the mascot of Wendy's who
had 81,000 Twitter followers at that
time but nothing and I mean nothing
could have prepared Ronald or his
company for what was about to happen
next
there you
are let go of
him run for
run that's a clip from the movie clown
which after a few delays came out in the
United States on June 17th 2016 this
movie Mostly didn't find an audience
outside of the horror movie fandom but
it may have played a part in setting up
one of the strangest and in my opinion
best hysteria is to sweep North America
that fall come ony come
ony what's where are you going you're
getting oh my God oh my God oh my God
okay what the no this is not
happening this is not fing
real he's right after this hit it hit
that hit
that creepy clown side ings are
happening across the country and it's no
laughing matter this is an absolute
nightmare oh my God I just want to fish
dude clown sightings the trend that's
terrifying people across North America
with sightings in more than half of the
United States as well as Canada and
Mexico group of clowns that are trying
to lure kids into the woods no one
really knows why it's happening one
theory is the remake of it based on
Stephen King's B now they're threatening
school districts dude what the what
[Music]
hey what are you
doing Chaos on campus with hundreds of
Penn State students in a state of panic
oh my God what the the McDonald's
corporation was asking themselves the
same thing and with the 2016 clown craze
reaching a fever pitch as Halloween
approached that year a decision had to
be made about the future of Ronald
McDonald he's one of the most wck
recognizable faces to Children worldwide
but the recent rash of creepy clown
sightings is hurting Ronald McDonald's
marketability Ronald McDonald a fixture
of the McDonald's food chain since 1963
is going to take a little vacation
saying in a statement McDonald's and
franchises in the local markets are
mindful of the current climate around
clown sightings in the communities and
as such are being thoughtful in respect
to Ronald McDonald's participation in
community events for the time being at
this point Ronald was the last remaining
character from The Old McDonald Land so
his being forced into a leave of absence
was truly the end of an era and after
going over his entire history watching
more than 10 hours of McDonald's
commercials watching several movies and
limited series reading hundreds of
Articles and scrubbing entire social
media accounts somewhere along the way I
think I figured out Ronald's true
[Music]
motivation what is Ronald true goal in
all of this what is the true source of
his power there are basically two
constants throughout his story kids and
Magic throughout crafting this episode I
became convinced that they are linked
Ronald's time around kids definitely
coincides with his occult activity so I
started to ask myself what is it about
kids that gives Ronald his power at
times it appears that he may be eating
them but there's no proof and frankly no
trail of missing kids at some point I
considered the idea that he's trying to
fatten them up but that got debunked in
the 20 when his exercise DVD still
featured him using plenty of Magic the
only time we really saw his magic power
start to dwindle was the decade after
when he struggled to stay in touch with
the youth and floundered his way through
curating a failing social media account
that's when I realized his power doesn't
come from kids at all it comes from
influence think back to that passage
about Pennywise from it if bait were
needed why what child did not love a
clown Pennywise took the form of a clown
to lure in kids and feed on their fear
but Willard Scott turned himself into a
clown because kids are the easiest
people to influence his first move was
to make the kids trust him so he gained
influence in the'80s he convinced the
kids to think he was cool by trying
every activity Under the Sun to make
himself look cool and he gained
influence he gained so much influence
that he had them eating processed food
sanitized in pink slime and climbing to
epidemic levels of obesity and when
people took notice of what he was up to
he actually got those little lard balls
to exercise look at the data from the
Center for Disease Control childhood
obesity grew every year from Ronald's
introduction to 2003 right when he
shifted his messaging to be all about
health and clean eating then the numbers
dipped for the first time and continued
to Trend downward until Ronald was
sidelined in the early 10 there were
obviously other factors as well but his
21st century exercise tirade actually
fing worked which means he had influence
and when he was told he had to step back
from the commercials he found a new way
to influence those kids which happens to
be my favorite way to influence
influenced by fear moving statues
stories of crucified kids and ball pit
Mayhem it's no wonder kids started
seeing him as an icon of horror videos
of Ronald McDonald imposters flooded the
internet people created fan-made horror
games fake commercials 3:00 a.m.
challenges and bizarre viral videos and
this meant that Ronald lost control of
the narrative he no longer had the
influence they did and Ronald's power
was quickly dwindling his Instagram went
quiet in 2021 today Ronald still makes
occasional appearances from time to time
popping up on McDonald's social media or
surfacing at a parade but for the most
part his time in the Limelight seems to
be over even his old friend Grimace got
a bigger marketing push in 2023 than he
did it seems that in the world of
influencers and social media Ronald can
get the attention of kids but he can't
keep it like he once could his Cult of
children was no more and that's why I
found it interesting when I came across
this and the cross as his symbol and use
them
to to make his point we are slaves we
have new God instead of the old God and
we pray for McDonald's this is MC Jesus
not to be confused with the Edmonton
Oilers Center a life-size sculpture
created by Finnish artist jany Lenin
which went up in hia Israel in 2019
after 56 years it seems Ronald finally
found someone more easily influenced
than children super religious people
according to Independence the piece
sparked protests which turned violent
and three police officers were injured
as demonstrators tried to break in to
where the statue was being held people
were deeply offended the culture
Minister threatened to cut funding and
the sculpture ultimately had to be
removed for the time being but this was
probably still a win for Ronald because
the chaos that he created was still
influence the statue hasn't emerged
again since then but don't be surprised
if it somehow disappears from wherever
it's being stored or turns its head and
speaks to the night Watchman the only
question is how far McDonald's will go
to cover it up like Pennywise Ronald is
dormant again for now if you like this
video you'll definitely want to check
out my Horror history episode on Grimace
you can find that one on the left if you
love horror make sure you subscribe to
cz's world for new Horrors every week
ring the death bell and select all
notifications so you don't miss an
upload and I will see you in the next
one assuming we both
survive